single-particle cryo-electron microscopy  or cryo am is an advancing technology  that is bringing key molecules into  focus here's how it works first the  molecules are suspended in a solution  then the solution is placed onto a fine  mesh screen called a grid the grid is  blotted to remove excess liquid and so  that the molecules are spread out in a  single layer to stop the movement of the  molecules and protect them during  imaging the grid is quickly cooled to  around minus 200 degrees Celsius next  the grid is loaded into a cassette and  put under the scope these molecules are  too small to be seen with visible light  instead electrons are used to visualize  them images of thousands of identical  molecules viewed at different  orientations are compiled into a highly  detailed molecular map as the techniques  and technology improve cryo-em  could be helpful in understanding the  basic molecules of the body and  designing drugs to treat disease  [Music]